[Music]
Karin warden with some courage the radio
show we're outside the studio with Lukas
McNally it's awesome to be able to meet
him in person like we said earlier it's
like we're meeting a celebrity or we're
very excited
you may remember Lucas's campaign your
without rent on Kickstarter and he's
been going across country taking a set
photos volunteering his time he's also
director of a country and we will be
screening his film Blanc de Blanc
tonight very excited about that but we
had one question come in while we were
on the radio with MJ slide our guest for
today and it was from Matt Crowell
Coyle I'm sorry Mike well it's at Matt
Coyle on Twitter and his question was
what's been the most memorable part of
the year without rent can't be in so far
well and hi Matt how are you I've known
Matt for like a really long time anyway
um probably the most memorable things so
far comes from first production Madsen
Tomlin's dream lover was the trailer is
out now and looks fantastic we had this
situation when we we had to build this
endless bed thing on a soundstage so if
like four mattresses all put together
like sheets going up and then we had a
woman in makeup for six hours from a
monster and then we had a sex scene and
then the monster is involved it's a
whole thing but it was really the
weirdest day that you could think
imagine on an independent film and like
nothing is really gotten close to that
in terms of just pure like one day pure
insanity or as I went on party lives I'm
Artie Lange's project right after that
editing and they were trying to add a
Taylor fart noises
they're complaining that there was no
Mejia compete with the monster texting
thing with the fart noises so I mean
nothing has really gotten close to that
point yet although we did film like
right next to the Golden Gate Bridge the
other day which was kind of cool
I almost got customs won't let me into
Canada for a little while
that was interesting why well my
passport got lost and so not lost my
house we're gonna damage to my car
because I think I left it would go down
or something
so need a new passport was a whole big
mess now I got there and my car's full
of stuff and they're like why I mean
Canada well I'm volunteering on this
film project I'm how do you know this
people all I know them through Twitter
he's perfect Oreo West stuff thing and
they're like when you mean you know
through Twitter and they started asking
questions and they took my phone and
they have you go in and talk to the
person that I like like what are you my
water rifle film current filmmaker
magazine in some places like so you work
for that I know like well how are you
doing this I'm like well we proud sort
funded it on Kickstarter so you work for
Kickstarter no so did the Kickstarter
hey you know and I had to explain for
how funding tour and I explained
filmmaker magazine and film courage and
all this stuff and took like an hour and
they made me go sit down and then she
got my phone I come back to reading my
emails and she's like what's who's this
much person because Mike
beby ours I forget how to say his last
name I'm like oh that's just somebody
else I know in Vancouver and we're gonna
you know get some food tonight I know
him through Twitter the whole and just
started all over again and so the lesson
to tell people you've met these people
have film festivals I think that's the
trick don't give them your phone one to
tell them you met at a film festival
because then it's like a real life thing
I think they thought it was in lieu
Canada or something because Mike
like someone who's moving but then
coming back into the country was easy
guys like where you going I'm like to
see I'm like I'm on a long road trip
that's some story reminds me of a scene
in the movie gotcha
did you ever see that movie where he's a
terribie anyway awesome pass the subject
here oh one question I want to ask you
was a quote that was actually on MG
slides blog and it was by Jim Jarmusch
and it was basically about how kind of
all artists are thief's then he says
don't bother concealing your thievery
celebrate if you feel like it and he
takes a quote from jean-luc Godard it's
not where you take things from it's
where you take things too how would you
feel about someone borrowing from your
work
what if someone doesn't give her that
mortgage and they go on this thing and
they they volunteer their time on film
sets yeah I mean it's really it's a
question of admitting it you know I mean
I'm I'm a big I don't like turn T know
like at all because I think he steals
from people and like pretends that he
doesn't or something and likes to act
like you know it's this great new idea
he had and it's just you know good order
film because that's he's like pulp
fiction you're watching pulp fiction and
then you watch a band apart you go I've
seen this movie already you go oh I'm
watching Pulp Fiction
but the original version way back when
so you know I think I would have a
problem with it I I had with Blanc I had
a thing where it looks like it got
stolen but I think it was saw blandish
that I can't imagine how it got stolen
but and I because we were gonna mention
we want to save this for tonight so you
have to watch Blanc tonight and then see
if you can figure out which
oscar-winning film then did the exact
same thing we did that was filming after
our movie was playing
theatres or up theater so I mean that
was really weird and it was one of those
things where I'm sort of watching the
movie okay whatever them like holy [ __ ]
what the hell is this okay how do I
respond to this you know like like what
are you but you just sort of you know
you explode yeah I think someone's
watching movies for the next room you
know good so we'll save that for the Q&A
yes we will have 2 min I'm film courage
calm or Facebook Phil courage one last
question that I have is how do you
balance in all this I mean you are just
a Content beast I mean you put up just
amazing post like you know every three
days or how are you balancing well the
thing is when you're not when you're on
the road you don't really have a life
because nobody's calling you to come
over for dinner and he's like oh come
hang out with us even do anything else
you know and so I've gotten pretty good
at working on stuff on set because
there's always that downtime on set I
see so I have my trusty bag here that
has everything in it and so I can edit
photos on set usually and I mean I'm
really behind actually I still owe 10
things like 10 things that I have to
post still so you know if you have a
12-hour day
you have a couple more hours on the tail
end of that we're working on stuff I'm
pretty good at writing those things
really quickly didn't be better if I
wrote them less quickly but there's so
much stuff to write that it just you
know I try to get something every other
day if I can
yeah well you do have plans we're going
to subway right so he is being invited
out for lunch this is the most social
life ahead months going to subway this
is fantastic
it's cuz it's not the break don't set
and then I don't need to go to subway
you know it's like they take the subway
order and they bring the subway what's
he set so I don't even get to leave
right we will get to enjoy the dining
experience at Subway and chips and a
drink a whole meal deal and it'll be a
good time so yeah thank you and then
we'll do the QA and then there will be
panels and it will be like the coolest
thing to ever happen to indie film ever
- other cool things and then I'm gonna
go back on set that's right so you have
a call time right afterwards money is
like seven so my goal is to not let
Nathan Colby be drunk okay and then get
back because we're filming in a seedy
hotel outside and I have somehow gone
from helping out to being the department
head of what's in this movie in like two
weeks so
you know okay probably should be there
for that
okay cuz it's the one part wasn't me in
a PA so I don't think he knows how to
run the lights
this should be interesting let's see
what happens when I get the high and
memorable la day well thank you yes
thank you
[Music]